india has accused china of violating
border agreements
as the armies of both countries engage
in a tense standoff
along a disputed himalayan border
speaking in parliament indian defense
minister rajnath singh
said china had unilaterally altered the
status quo
along the border he also assured members
that the army was well prepared
for any eventuality and contingency
plans were in place
to ensure india's sovereignty
we have informed china through
diplomatic and military channels that
such activities are an effort to change
the status quo unilaterally
and it has been made amply clear that
these efforts are not acceptable to us
under any conditions
this year's recent incidents of violent
conduct of chinese forces are a complete
violation of all mutually agreed norms
according to the current situation the
chinese side has mobilized its armed
forces and sent
ammunition on the lac and internal areas
china has meanwhile reiterated that a
recent agreement between top
officials of both sides should form the
basis for the easing of tensions
during the meeting in moscow the foreign
ministers of
china and india reached a positive
consensus on jointly easing and cooling
the border situation
and we will continue to maintain close
communication through military and
diplomatic channels to resolve issues on
the ground
we hope that india will earnestly
implement the consensus reached by the
foreign ministers of the two sides
meet china halfway and make concrete
efforts to ease the situation
is a journalist and strategic affairs
analyst who's been reporting on the
india china
border standoff since it began months
ago welcome
the foreign ministers of uh both sides
agreed last week in moscow the chinese
and indian troops would quote
disengage from their current standoff
points
is that plan already dead given that
both sides are actually reinforcing
their positions as we speak
well this has been the norm since the
start of this crisis to say one thing
and do another and the chinese from the
time they entered indian territory which
was uh
towards the early part of may
have been firstly saying that they have
not transgressed the line of control
they are in chinese territory
and secondary secondly calling for
disengagement
and withdrawal but not actually doing it
on the ground
now the indian side has had the time to
build up troops as well
uh along the border along the line of
actual control
and the same thing is happening there is
one set of
rhetoric that is going on and the other
is a far more aggressive and a far more
worrying
deployment and counter deployment that
is going on on the ground
that is bringing the troops into face
with each uh with each other
and setting the stage for violence so
that's a worrying proposition
you spoke about indian territory and the
lse or the line of actual control
now indian defense minister rajnath
singh said in parliament that there are
court
deferring perceptions of the line of
actual control which
is of course the line across which this
standoff is taking place the opposition
congress is saying that the phrase
deferring perceptions of the lac
legitimizes china's claim
does it oh well yes in a way
because uh a government in a country has
to be quite clear where its borders lie
and if the other country the country
with whom it has a disputed border
says that the border does not lie in
place x but lies in place y
uh then this country cannot start saying
deferring perceptions and so on and so
forth
uh each country has to be clear where
its border lies uh
in a way if you are if you're
rationalizing this uh
this issue of deferring perceptions
you're also rationalizing aggressive
action by the other side to capture the
border up to where
that country believes its border lies so
uh i think that there's a there's a bit
of uh
sort of excuse making that is going on
over here when they're talking about uh
deferring perceptions the fact is that
the chinese have entered into
a territory that lies on the indian side
of the indian perceptions
and from india's viewpoint there can be
only one set of perceptions
so to that extent this is a bit of an
excuse-making uh
sort of statement it sort of seeks to
justify
china coming into territory that india
claims
that india has always held and that
india has patrolled for years
and if i'm not wrong there are reports
that some 1 000 square kilometers of
territory
that india claims as its own is now
inaccessible to indian troops
is this something that the government is
actually concerned about
yes the government is very concerned
about this uh the loss of territory
especially in the south asian context
is a very emotive subject so
this figure itself this 1000 square
kilometers
has been arrived at by joining uh
several points of incursion so to that
extent it's a it's not a
really valid figure but the fact is that
china has at at least
four or five different points along the
line of actual control
ingressed into indian claimed territory
to a distance of
15 to 16 kilometers at the deepest and
uh two or three kilometers at the
shallow points
so uh all these things add up to the
loss of a significant amount of
territory
and that's a very emotive subject and
something that the government is very
careful in handling
final question to you sir do you think
china and india are now
in this for the long haul
oh well that that's hard to say uh i
would say that
both countries would not like to get
into a winter deployment
uh in an area where temperatures
routinely go down to minus 20 and minus
30 degrees centigrade
where there's a windchill factor where
high altitude causes
very serious limitations to how much a
human body can bear and do
so taking on a winter deployment which
is something that would not
appeal to the chinese or the indian side
so both have a very strong reason to
de-escalate
and we'll have to wait and see if they
do that over the next two months
we'll leave it there for the time being
but thank you so much for joining us